[Musique]
article 132 163 les délits de traite
d'humain et de proxinétisme pardon
j'étais en train de lire le code pédal
je suis dans le bureau du Bâtonnier des
avocats de Versailles Maître Olivier
fontibus et ben justement si on parlait
de ce que c'est le bâtonnet de ce que
sont les avocats avec Maître Olivier
fontibus Maître Olivier fontibus bonjour
et merci de de nous recevoir on est dans
votre bureau de de bâtonnier de jeune
bâtonnier puisque vous avez été élu
l'année dernière mais vous vous venez de
prendre vos fonctions au fond absolument
je suis heureux de vous recevoir donc
dans ce bureau historique historique oui
c'est le bureau traditionnel du
bâtonnier de Versailles au sein du
Palais de Justice qui est l'ancien
bureau du président du tribunal dans les
années 60 d'accord alors un un bâtonnier
en quelques mots voilà il est élu par
ses pères euh et sa fonction ça consiste
en quoi elle est multiple euh le barreau
le bâtonnier représente l'ordre euh il
gère l'ordre il administre l'ordre il
règle les conflits entre les
justiciables et les avocats de son
barreau et les conflits entre les
avocats eux-mêmes il est aussi celui qui
peut poursuivre des confrères qui ne
respecterait pas la règle déontologique
h h un peu le procureur des avocats
puisque il a le pouvoir de les déférer
devant le conseil régional de discipline
voilà qui est conseil disciplinaire on
arrive à à mener les les deux carrières
en même temps c'estàd celle d'avocat
parce que vous continuez évidemment à
avir votre votre cabinet et puis celle
de de bateer parce que je suppose que ça
prend beaucoup de temps ça prend
beaucoup de temps c'est vrai que c'est
un sacerdoce c'est un engagement que
l'on prend mais je tiens et c'est
souvent la règle à rester avocat et à
continuer à plaider on ne peut pas
défendre les intérêts des confrères si
on n'est pas soi-même je dirais au cœur
des difficultés et puis ça ne dure que 2
ans donc il n pas question d'abandonner
son cabinet pendant 2 ans he les
associés ne seraient pas très heureux
les clients non plus et puis je pense
que ça me manquerait donc il faut
effectivement faire vivre ces deux
activités qui sont difficilement
compatible mais on essaie qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à devenir bâtoner vous
présenter au bâtonnais devenir bâtonier
vous le disiez je suis bâtonnier depuis
le 1er janvier 2012 mais j'avais été
antérieurement du conseil de l'ordre
entre 1996 et 2002 et puis je m'étais
représenté en 2010 je crois que c'est la
continuité ou l'aboutissement d'un
engagement j'ai toujours estimé que
l'ordre dans notre profession était
incontournable c'est l'essence même de
la profession d'avocat c'est ce qui nous
permet à nous avocats de faire notre
métier tous les jours parce que nous
savons que derrière nous il y a un ordre
qui nous protège et qui aussi nous
surveille et qui nous contrôle l'avocat
est un professionnel libéral dans une
profession réglementée c'est une des
sécurité que nous apportons à nos
justiciables à nos clients donc c'est
vrai que la vie ordinale est importante
elle rythme le vie la vie de l'avocat
elle lui permet d'exercer en toute
tranquillité et en toute en toute
comment dirais-je en contrôle et c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu effectivement
m'investir très tôt dans la vie ordinale
alors parler des des fonctions
évidemment de de disciplinaire de de
l'ordre il y a je dir pas une fonction
politique mais mais c'est vrai que les
ordres des avocats d'une façon générale
ont ont beaucoup agit notamment pour des
réformes je pense notamment à la réforme
de la garde à vue qui aurait sans doute
pas vu vu le jour sans le sans le la
pression des avocats absolument alors
vous avez raison il y a je dirais le
bâtonnier qui est tourné vers
l'intérieur vers son barreau et puis
l'organisation de la profession en
France est ainsi fait que les bâtonniers
ont une un rôle à jouer important un
nous sommes quasiment tous les barreaux
les 160 barreaux français à l'exception
de Paris membres de la Conférence des
Bâtonniers donc tous les bâtonniers
français à part Paris est à part puisque
Paris représente à peu près 50 % de la
profession donc un rôle un peu et un
rôle une place à part et puis à côté il
y a des barreaux de 10 20 30 personnes
700 puisque à Versailles nous sommes 716
nous sommes à peu près le 12 ou 13e
barreau français et l'ensemble des
bâtonniers se retrouve soit dans la
Conférence des Bâtonniers donc instance
politique d'influence soit dans la
conférence des sens la conférence des 20
plus grands barreaux français où nous
représentons nous à 20 barreaux à peu
près l'équ du barreau de Paris d'accord
pr 23 très important exactement donc
c'est vrai que nous nous réunissons à
peu près une fois tout les 2 mois et
nous faisons avancer des dossiers
avançons des dossiers autant des
dossiers internes mais externes ça a été
la garde à vue ça a été bien entendu ce
qu'on a appelé la la la suppression des
avoués la dématérialisation des
procédures enfin tous les grands sujets
de la profession sont abordés par les
bâtonniers qui se réunissent
régulièrement c'est quand même une
profession par tradition très
individuelle dualistes les avocats et il
y a en même temps un courant qui vient
probablement un peu des États-Unis enfin
notamment des pays anglosaxons qui
constitu des des immense cabinet où
est-ce qu'ils on sont les avocats
français entre cette culture
traditionnelle de l'individualisme de
l'avocat et puis ce besoin peut-être
aussi de se regrouper vous avez raison
l'avocat peut-être individualiste il est
souvent h parce que la relation avec son
client lui impose cette relation
contractuelleement d'omme à hom on
travaille plus ou moins nombreux dans
des cabinets mais cet individualisme a
toujours été tempéré par l'ordre par le
fait que nous sommes toujours en contact
au sein de nos ordres et que la le
caractère collectif de la profession est
aussi une dimension totalement
importante nous savons être
individualiste et nous savons aussi être
solidairire je crois que nous sommes
tous solidaires au sein d'un barreau et
c'est raison pour laquelle le fait de
travailler à plusieurs est aujourd'hui
une nécessité nous avons un barreau JEE
jeune ouis un barreau féminisé alors
vous disiez 716 76 avocats 62 % de
femmes mais c'est une profession qui se
féminise énormément exactement mais on
est un petit peu plus haut que la
moyenne et l'âge moyen est de 43 ans ah
oui donc nous sommes un Barau jeune et
féminisé mais nous savons aussi que
l'avenir est dans la structuration des
cabinets et c'est la raison pour
laquelle en tout cas c'est un message
que je lance à chaque fois vers les
jeunes confrères qui nous rejoignent
c'est de travailler ensemble je crois
qu'aujourd'hui à la fois pour l'avocat
mais aussi pour le client il est
important que les intelligences soient
mélangées que l'on puisse véritablement
compter sur des associés sur des
collaborateurs pour à la fois se
sécuriser soi-même et sécuriser les
clientèles parce que on est toujours on
est toujours moins ignorant à plusieurs
que seul dans dans cette sociologie du
du barreau
versailla je sais pas si on le sait mais
est-ce que ce sont souvent des gens qui
viennent qui des familles qui
appartiennent à cette profession ou
est-ce que il y a voilà des nouveaux
entrant si je peux dire non la
profession est très ouverte elle a
toujours été très très ouverte alors
c'est vrai que certains barreaux avaient
un peu l'image de la tradition le
Barreau de Versailles en est pas exemp
mais c'est vrai que en en 25 ans en 30
ans le barreau de versaill a totalement
explosé il y a il y a 25 ans 30 ans nous
étions 250 on est aujourd'hui 716 je
crois que la sociologie à la fois de la
ville de Versailles a changé le Barreau
de Versailles a changé je vous le disais
62 % de femmes de nombreux jeunes
beaucoup de jeunes et qui viennent de
tous horizons à la fois des horizons
géographiques différents et sociaux
totalement différents donc on ne peut
pas dire aujourd'hui que dira que le
barreau dans sa globalité et le barreau
de versaill en particulier soit
constitué de fils de maître comme on les
appelait il y a à peu près 40 ou 50 ans
et vous dis vous êtes passé comme ça de
200 à plus de
700 est-ce que ça veut dire que c'est
aussi une vie difficile celle d'avocat
est-ce que on gagne sa vie facilement ou
est-ce que c'est c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça l'a été c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué que ça ne l'a été c'est
vrai qu'il y a eu les les années
heureuses je dirais dans les années 70
60 70 où là le barreau s'est développé
et où les professions libérales
effectivement on ont eu des des années
fastueuse aujourd'hui c'est difficile il
est évident que même si on espère
toujours euh que les jeunes vont
remplacer ceux qui vont partir les baby
boomers qui sont là pour le coup sur le
départ hein on a une courbe on a une
courbe qui s'amenuise dans les années
201000 2016 on a on va avoir beaucoup de
départ donc il est important de ne pas
faire ce fait les médecins par exemple
ou avec ces clauses de de numérous
clausus qui ont effectivement asséché
voilà qui se sont qui ont asséché la
prodction médicale donc là on peut le
dire la profession d'avocat n'est pas
sous cette crainte au contraire mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes ont
du mal à trouver des stages ont du mal à
sortir je dirais avec un stage de
l'école d'avocat mais bon même si ça
devient difficile maintenant de devenir
avocat alors oui effectivement parce que
Ben les les les les IJ les institut
d'études judiciaires ont compris qu'on
ne pouvait pas déverser dans la
profession autant de de jeunes qu'on le
qu'on l'a fait il y a quelques années
qui ne trouvaiitent pas effectivement de
stage à l'issue de l'école vousmême vous
êtes spécialiste de droit social oui euh
c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui de se
spécialiser autre fois alors je
notamment en province enfin si je peux
dire que versaill est la province je sa
pas mais c'est vrai que voilà c'est
avocats étaient plutôt des avocats
généralistes aujourd'hui il y a de plus
en plus de spécialisation parce que le
droit est plus compliqué parce que oui
oui la spécialisation est une nécessité
c'est une nécessité parce que un les
gens la réclament parce que je pense
qu'on est tous conscients que le droit
est devenu extrêmement complexe
extrêmement divers diversifié et qu'on
ne peut plus être généraliste ou alors
Sion est généraliste on va se cantonner
à une activité extrêmement limitée mais
on devra ensuite orienter le client vers
un spécialiste de la matière donc
j'incite les jeunes confrères et les
autres également à se spécialiser nous
ne sommes pas assez spécialisés au
Barreau de Versailles aujourd'hui nous
avons une réforme de la spécialisation
qui va être plus simple qui va être qui
va reposer sur la pratique des confrères
et non pas sur un examen je dirais assez
universitaire donc la pratique sera
sanctionnée et j'incite et j'invite les
confrères notamment du Barau de
Versailles à se spécialiser ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on fait pas autre chose mais
on est un peu plus à même de comprendre
un dossier d'en défendre un dans le
cadre d'une spécialisation bien compris
et l'information de cette spécialisation
comment elle vient au au justiciable
alors ça c'est tout le problème c'estàd
que ça c'est le rôle de de l'ordre he ce
que je dis souvent au confrères c'est
que on a comment dirais-je une règle
d'or à Versailles c'est la proximité des
compétences on a des compétences on a 7
16 compétences encore faut-il les faire
connaître alors c'est à nous de les
promouvoir par le site internet par la
publicité fonctionnelle que l'ordre peut
effectivement faire auprès des
justiciables nous avons par exemple
exemple créé il y a quelques années le
Centre d'Information du Barreau de
Versailles qui est un un centre qui
permet d'orientation et qui permet à
tout justiciable d'avoir un rendez-vous
chez un spécialiste h pour la modique
somme de 30 € qui est une contribution
je dirais au fonctionnement du centre et
c'est une un premier rendez-vous
d'orientation chez un avocat spécialiste
puis ensuite on voit si je dirais le
feeling est passé si le si si
véritablement on souhaite aller plus
loin avec l'avocat mais on a et on offre
parce que c'est le rôle de l'ordre de
faciliter le contact
entre le justiciable et un avocat
spécialiste et nous allons faire la même
chose avec les entreprises on va
permettre aux entreprises aux petits
entrepreneurs aux PME aux commerçants
qui ont toujours très peur de l'avocat
de premier contact avec
l'avocat d'avoir un premier contact
montrer que c'est pas si compliqu
compliqué que ça pour pour conclure
voilà on parlait de ce barreau de
versaill qui qui vous fait partie des
barreaux les plus importants de France
mais vous êtes un peu le petit poussé à
côté de l'ogre parisien comment défend
par qu'il faut se défendre d'abord et on
vit quoifoui il faut se défendre
pourquoi il faut se défendre tout
simplement pour que la place de versaill
mais comme les autres places je dirais
régionales restent des places juridiques
et que l'on n pas toujours le réflexe
d'aller vers Paris alors on se défend
par être en étant compétent et en
expliquant à nos justiciables aux
habitants des ivelines et plus si
affinité que à Versailles il y a des
gens compétents qui peuvent leur offrir
les mêmes services que des avocats
parisiens hein il y a ce centralisme qui
effectivement est très gênant en France
dans le monde juridique et judiciaire
comme partout ailleurs mais je pense que
la proximité est importante c'est
essentiel la proximité de la justice la
proximité des auxiliaires de justice des
avocats et cette cette proximité bien
entendu doit s'accompagner des
compétences et c'est cela que je veux
mettre en exerg durant ce bâtonin alors
sou très beau bâtonin il encore 2 ans de
2 ans de travail pour vous et merci
infiniment de nous avoir reu
[Musique]
mercius